welcome to this video playing night
leave in the 2510 pool on icc what am I
going to do yep the Queens gambit
accepted share I only yesterday got a
new book released on that opening and I
am giving you give it a try without
having any idea that really I just know
that knight c6 is supposed to be a
decent move him Quincy for actually as
viewed with suspicion i think because of
a 5 hmm but don't ask me how exactly it
works
what is it bishop e6 actually yeah I
cannot look it up in the book that would
be cheating hmm e 595 Bishop is 60 yeah
it is so II 595 bishop is 696 Bishop c4
98 rock the aid maybe they normally play
Knight c3 and not capture and see form
doctor should be six looks kind of
strange to block the upon if I go a five
de five Bishop e6 Queen a four I don't
know okay definitely look that up after
the game I know that night crete xe4
it's not that great but no idea why if
five actually looked logical but I
couldn't really figure out what um what
the precise way to play is yeah here I'm
definitely playing this or maybe Bishop
t5 actual name is Bishop t5 an idea
putting some pressure on deform I like
95 them
496 yeah but still maybe this is just
the worse version of that line web white
place 593 Knight c3 now looks fairly
okay so Bishop g4 I guess intending you
five
yeah it has a distinct gruene felt feel
good 52 really it was quickly played
surprisingly was that a mouth slit maybe
that he just accidentally clicked with
c1 and that's a smart move should be two
looks but we had ok I think I go e5 now
that's an opportunity I shouldn't waste
well nineteen ninety five hundred isn't
that nice for me I don't quite
understand night ed three check is a
possibility and it cannot even play the
bishop out yeah 93 now is that just
working or is that not greed yeah 93
King f1 night be to queen bee three and
this is probably trapped well maybe
night if for as weird as it looks 93
check King moves night be too then back
to a four but should be five check
Bishop to sell but that this indeed
working
93 k of one night be to Quincy tone
night to to a for Queenie for check
should be six Queen B 795 Quincy six
check Bishop 27 and it is trapped that's
a funky line yeah if I don't play 93 @
kind of it's kind of pointless let's do
that meanie probably after all that
calculation you will just down he will
just take it and accept to be to verse
forever now that was that's not critical
critical was only king of one yeah the
Queens gambit accepted is a very
interesting opening actually and one of
them truly underestimated once it's
played very very rarely and in fact it
would be a good opening for many people
because it leads to relatively open
positions yeah for people who enjoy um
free piece play development the Queens
gambit accepted is a pretty good option
now you open up the position right on
move to that's interesting so why keep
on to move the Queen really
ok I think I have to take you one so
also no intermediate things night cheeks
and now if i go to age 59 f 4 is a bit
awkward so i go here so we have a
position with equal material but black
has two bishops i didn't expect that one
I thought that the night is just not
very stable on that square I'm already
threatening a 5a five wins now or C 5
wins
hmm i don't think that night before was
great really maybe he had to I mean but
what exactly now
it's awkward it's quite awkward this
position forward even all the moves are
failing air like Bishop c3 or 93 or
something that no there's something off
already so if 592 where that's not
really that great night efore is
interesting b3 night c5 is very nice but
actually many possibilities long castles
at least prevents white from canceling
short just because of Bishop takes be
one rupee one rooty to
gen eight a form almost certainly Nets
the total vision p.m. sorry oops yep
it's too tempting to bishops against two
nights simply because that Bishop has
nowhere to go nowhere to run to nowhere
to hide but am I taking it really that's
a good question I don't think I have to
let's gain some space push that back to
a two
he cannot go 92 because of Knight c3 so
how to continue now be three years
becoming a little bit more like lame
okay I'm just blocking that Bishop
normal move it's no particular reason to
to rush with anything
you cannot move any office minor pieces
ready well okay too silly positions
Bishop to you one or something I really
think be three can be considered now
then I'll take c3 giving me the as
mentioned total bishops tumblr bishop
pair yeah here we go yeah we retreating
it's not that bad but neither is taking
so let's take it so let's see him that
Bishop is best on e6 probably or what
about Bishop c2
yeah i can go here that's the good news
actually root g1s bishop see tool that
is strong and ok rock III
yep let's activate and always keep
pressure on the Knights two nights that
protect each other usually mean that
both of them cannot move
cheap with the rook and the good thing
is that check it's not just a bishop
pair which in itself is pretty pretty
awesome but i also have a majority on
the queenside that is very quick very
quickly and set in motion now and we
were relatively quickly probably cost
one of the nights i can even teak
actually it's okay it's not really
necessary to give up one of the one of
the bishops a5 b5 and so on is coming
okay to be 394 ok I'm going forward
there's also quite a substantial
difference in King activity so check
worth no let's just push things
okay so b3m just be three yo should
winner is there anything left in terms
of tricks I don't see it night c5 I can
take seat to actually check yeah take
this and go be to go and that's a new
queen yeah two bishops against two
nights with chances for passage just to
win white resign nothing more nothing
less yum so he played a somewhat strange
opening I'm really unsure hear what the
best movers here i can actually let me
fetch that book ok so the book actually
gives you five and then the same which
is cut curious 9085 interesting move
yeah of course is interesting this is
what I calculate and what it would be a
novelty that's cool that's a novelty
that looks like the most Nolan whatever
and they give this yeah i saw this but i
couldn't really come to a clear
conclusion they give this night you for
Bishop f4 g5 wow you three and 95 with
dynamic play your that is certainly true
okay well I won't be should be six
when here yeah and now i don't know i
mean this this is kind of kind of normal
idea III looks uncritical I don't know
maybe this is this goes back and this
that might be might be something looks
like a fairly normal position after all
maybe after some some tempo losses by
matts by both sides okay went here here
back here and now he played the really
weird looking move Bishop t2 that was
played instantly I really wanted that
was some kind of smart move mouse slip
okay five chicks and now widest fighting
for equality and gets difficult okay
yeah now king of one is stony move
really well let's say the only move of
some interest hmm he goes some king of
one I was thinking and I could maybe
take it but here the engine seems to
disagree check a and then his check I I
cannot lose a piece yeah I was actually
thinking that I can always go back here
yeah if everything else fails I really
would have checked them with some yeah
scrutiny if that's really working taking
won't be too yes to play King have one
after this he is just worse for ever and
has to suffer at five txtx here right
yeah I think not f was just better this
is getting into trouble there this piece
and a three castles yeah the issue is he
has problems coordinating quite a bit
difficult for
losses right a forum Chim very awkward
and f6 just asking white waters next
move is ya b3 probably there is not not
much else develop stuff can yeah this is
this is probably just lost its two
bishops against two nights and plus the
king plus the the pawn probably even
taking wins on before but of course
that's unnecessary you can just lay it
as I as I didn't just push things slowly
forward Jim chances a touchdown already
if he takes here I'm taking him someone
key line check cure this and now this is
promoting yeah it's really not much to
do yeah the problem really was um he
played this this phase of the game from
here and really a pretty weird way and
you know king of one is the only move
that puts up a fight even if you are not
sure yeah about the be to pawn and then
let's say white wasn't completely sure
if this is really working I'd rather
give up this pawn and take on d3 because
this is kind of totally depressing king
of one at least looks kind of murky and
yeah you have to do it and objectively
it's not that bad I don't really think
that this is this whole term enough a
wide I mean let's say I know what I'm
doing here 27 Mary for long castles I
can do this
maybe something like this now is this
actually proper actually possible like
this this I know something here G foam
and trade down stuff I mean black is a
bit better but it's probably not not
that that big of a deal yeah probably
should have done something like that
this does this gets now really ugly and
now night FY is also a bit a bit
stronger I think your white still has
some more decent chances to a wood it's
not really fun yeah giving giving me the
bishops and three against you on the
queenside which is mobile and white is
not well coordinated and so on it's kind
of a yeah it's very uncomfortable to
play but yeah you can probably put up a
fast differ resistance here then known
compared to that night to be form okay
well thanks for watching